beyonce and jay-z pack on the pda at the
rapper's 52nd birthday celebration
[Music]
the drunken love singer took to
instagram on tuesday with a number of
photos from the night like any good
celebration there was cake and wine and
of course a major fashion moment from b
in this video the singer shows off her
sparkly silver gucci by balenciaga suit
while flipping her hair and putting on
sunglasses for dramatic effect beyonce
even gave us close-ups of her sparkly
accessories proving it's all in the
details on that note i'm going to take
my seat meanwhile the birthday boy kept
it casual wearing a dark jacket jeans
and a hat and did we mention the
couple's pda we're especially living for
these sweet kissing shots of course jay
has had lots to celebrate this year last
month he was inducted into the rock and
roll hall of fame with daughter blue ivy
joining her mama and a number of other
famous faces in this pre-recorded
tribute video congrats us carter ghost
rider
you paid the right price so we just made
your hits tighter
the nine-year-old has obviously
inherited a thing or two from her
parents including a sense of style
[Music]
blue also appeared in b and j's recent
trey chic commercial for tiffany and co
looking every bit apart as she crashed
her parents parisian date night in the
back of a cab
he loves me
he loves me jay opened up to et back in
august about the best part of working
with his wife she's a
super um
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's uh incredibly
hard worker
super talented
very inspiring and speaking of inspiring
the rapper is paving the way towards
more representation in hollywood you do
know how to make a grand entrance he had
this to say about serving as co-producer
on the netflix film the harder they fall
a western featuring an all-black cast
one in three cowboys in the west was
black people don't know that
and so what did it mean to make this
western so when people see this west and
when kids click on netflix they'll look
at this and they'll hear those names
also yeah i just love to be a part of
projects that widen the lens you know
because once it's widened for us then
it's widened for you know asian for
you know mexican for everyone uh right
so
you know the idea of and this again one
in three so this really exists and
people really think that you know i mean
you can't fault them because that was
the images we effect on growing up like
one of the only things on you know
public television was westerns every
week you would get western so
um and we weren't we weren't represented
in those in those at all um in fact you
know you know our characters was taken
from us you know the lone ranger was
based on you know one of the characters
from this film